now to newly released video showing
police arresting voters in Florida it is
causing quite a stir a handful of
convicted felons were charged with voter
fraud back in August now they say they
had permission to register to vote even
though they were not eligible under
state law critics say that Florida's
governor is now trying to intimidate
potential voters and create confusion
over who was allowed to go to the polls
next month Ed O'Keefe is in Washington
with more on the story Ed good morning
it is very confusing if you're sitting
at home watching this it could be yes
Gail good morning the arrests were made
following investigations by new Florida
state police force established by
Republican Governor Ron DeSantis to
investigate voter fraud according to
local Reports most of those arrested
were black and registered Democrats
some voter fraud voter stuff in footage
obtained by CBS news on August 18th
police showed up at the Tampa home of
Tony Patterson a registered sex offender
who was told he was under arrest for
voter fronts
voting when you're not supposed to Sir
that same day Ramona Oliver who served
18 years on a second degree murder
charge was arrested for voting illegally
in 2020. even though she'd received a
voter ID card from the state
commit no fraud Patterson Oliver and 18
others were accused of violating a 2018
state law that allows most former felons
to vote after they complete their
sentences but that law excludes convicts
like Patterson and Oliver who were
convicted of a felony sex offense or
murder Florida Republican Governor Ron
DeSantis touted the arrests that same
day they are disqualified from voting
because they've been convicted of either
murder or sexual assault more than 11
million votes were cast in Florida in
the 2020 election when some of those
arrested allegedly illegally voted in
the videos first obtained by the Tampa
Bay Times Patterson tells a police
officer he was misled all right so far
let's walk over to my car okay we're all
doing this now and this happened years
ago I don't know voting rights Advocates
say it's a game of gotcha when people
get a voter ID card from their
government what else are they going to
presume except that they're eligible to
vote good evening in a debate Tuesday
night between Florida's U.S Senate
candidates these specific arrests didn't
come up but the candidates did spawn
over voting rights Florida has very good
election laws and the states that don't
have very good election laws are the
states that actually have gone in the
opposite direction of weakening security
for the ballot Florida has an election
law police force
and if the laws are so wonderful
why what's the need for that
Republican senator Marco Rubio and
Democrat Val Deming so you saw they are
locked in a close and expensive fight
AIDS the governor DeSantis who's running
for reelection this year against
Democrat Charlie Crist didn't return
requests for comment on the concerns
that some of those felons may have been
misled or confused by state law Nate
Ed thank you